fireteam Osiris over the last 72 hours  five colonies have experienced identical  events massive destruction forerunner  and origin but dr. Kathryn Lisbeth  Halsey has managed to contact us she  claims to have information on these  attacks palsy is currently in covenant  custody on the surface of Camp Chaddha  your mission is to insert behind enemy  lines retrieve Halsey and bring her back  to infinity  be advised dr. Halsey is accompanied by  covenant supreme leader Zhu Lim dama if  you have the opportunity understood  commander  good luck Spartan Locke the Trinity out  cracking gear online affirmative say  before we make this jump anybody want to  say a few words I figured Goggin here  I'm scared I am so can everyone else  lock fine first drink overdone you ask  you buy  fireteam Osiris the light is green  gotcha calm porcupine mom got me that to  dr. smart buckle on and ready dark veil  online  weapons three goddang  hmm get the Xbox one limited edition  bundle